[Musique]
il est rare d'entendre des personnalités
parlées de Dieu de foi de croyance de
religion notre invité le fait en toute
liberté sans tabou sans honte sans
hypocrisie en évoquant ces moments de
grâce et de joie intense mais en
évoquant aussi ses doutes ces critiques
ses reproches les bigoteries les
querelles de paroisse le commerce
religieux tout cela l'exaspère et c'est
cette liberté de ton et de pratique qui
a attiré l'attention du Vatican et du
pape François en personne c'est même
ceux-là qui lui a permis d'écrire le
défi de Jérusalem carnets de voyage très
intime sur son expérience en Terre
sainte alors telle que je vous le
présente vous croyez peut-être que notre
invité est un homme d'église mais non
notre invité est écrivain romancier
dramaturge réalisateur acteurs ces
livres se vendent par millions il est
l'un des auteurs francophones les plus
lus au monde les plus traduits les plus
représentés il fait jouer les plus
grandes stars dans ses pièces et ses
films Alain Delon Michèle Laroque
Catherine et aujourd'hui Emmanuel et
Mathilde Seigner comment fait-on pour
passer d'un entretien avec le pape à une
soirée people notre invité est-il un
pont entre différents mondes entre le
monde de l'art et celui de la
spiritualité entre celui du showbiz et
celui de la piété posant lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenu à vous Eric Emmanuel
Schmitt et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici au Sénat dans ce dôme
Tournon où êtes-vous le plus à l'aise le
plus à votre place dans la bibliothèque
du Vatican avec le pape ou dans une
soirée showbiz
je crois que c'est dans ma chambre à mon
bureau
peut-être que là je peux me retirer du
monde le réinventer et l'offrir aux gens
après à travers des histoires en fait je
n'aime que le retrait c'est toujours
pour moi un effort d'aller d'aller dans
le monde même s'il y a des bonnes
surprises dans ce monde et que je suis
passionné par les êtres humains mais
j'ai toujours besoin de ce recul du
retrait et puis de passer toute à
travers le filtre de l'écriture mais
c'est vrai que votre position est
particulière vous êtes une sorte
d'électrons libre entre vous survolez
différents les intégrer forcément
oui je me souviens j'avais mon prof de
philo quand j'étais en classe
préparatoire disait quand les hommes
s'assemblent leurs oreilles poussent
et effectivement j'ai peur des milieux
oui parce que je trouve qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un milieu c'est un ensemble de
préjugés partagés donc j'ai toujours
cultivé ma différence ma singularité pas
par narcissisme mais par presque par
hygiène intellectuelle je veux pas
partager des préjugés avec les gens d'où
cette liberté qui a été longtemps un
obstacle et qui maintenant attire des
gens extrêmement différents non
seulement vous n'avez pas envie d'être
enfermé dans un monde mais vous ne
voulez pas non plus être enfermé dans
une époque j'ai envie d'être toutes les
époques avez-vous dit c'est cela qui
vous a fait vous lancer dans le chantier
titanesque qu'elle a traversé des temps
ainsi que le romanesque qui retrace
l'histoire de l'humanité en huit tomes
vous vouliez raconter plusieurs époques
plusieurs sociétés j'ai quand même envie
de vous demander s'il y a une époque qui
vous plaît plus à laquelle vous auriez
aimé dans laquelle vous auriez aimé
vivre je crois qu'il y a deux époques
que j'adore et je vais bientôt les
aborder dans mon grand cycle romanesque
c'est la Grèce au quatrième siècle avant
Jésus-Christ l'invention du théâtre de
la philosophie de la démocratie donc
c'est c'est un moment c'est un saut
intellectuel extraordinaire et puis il y
a le 18e siècle le siècle des Lumières
et pourtant je suis croyant mais le
siècle des Lumières parce que c'est la
la liberté singulière de de de penser
par soi-même c'est le savoir partagé
c'est le statut de élevé de chacun
l'accès à la connaissance donc ces deux
siècles dont j'adore les grands
mouvements et notre époque elle vous
plaît notre époque actuelle
me plaît oui parce que elle est
elle est elle est infiniment riche puis
je pense qu'on vit une époque de bascule
avec avec l'arrivée du numérique bien
sûr de l'intelligence artificielle d'une
communication facile enfin la terre n'a
jamais été aussi petite elle est
minuscule maintenant et donc c'est assez
vertigineux
d'assister à ça et de vivre ce moment-là
tout de même vous avez fait le choix
d'être je vous cite le script de la joie
et vous dites malheureusement notre
époque ne valorise pas ma démarche
contrairement à l'accablement qui a
pignon sur rue on ne prend pas la joie
au sérieux est-ce que nous vivons dans
une époque qui se complait un peu dans
l'assainis rose complètement
particulièrement en France je crois
oui on a l'air intelligent quand on est
pessimiste on le pessimisme c'est pas
plus intelligent que le Christ c'est
juste une position quoi et puis vous
savez quand on entend les critiques
parler de livres on aime la noirceur de
quelque chose
oui on pourrait aimer le rosé aussi
ou la blancheur de quelque chose ben
bref c'est chaque époque assez préjugé
partagé assez conneries quoi et la nôtre
elle est comme les autres mais ce qu'il
y a c'est qu'évidemment quand on est
quand on est immergé dedans on les voit
pas c'est tout l'intérêt d'avoir une
formation philosophique moi je conseille
ça absolument tout le monde je veux dire
apprendre la philosophie ou plutôt
acquérir les outils philosophiques c'est
une manière de pouvoir penser par
soi-même de se dégager des influences
des préjugés du prêt-à-penser du
prépensé etc et
ça me paraît essentiel on devrait
enseigner qu'une chose dans les dans les
dans les lycées la philosophie l'amour
de la sagesse vous avez la foi vous
l'avez dit et vous la partagez cette
fois vous évoquez publiquement et vous
écrivez vos expériences mystiques depuis
de nombreuses années il y a eu la
rencontre avec Dieu dans le désert du
Sahara quand vous étiez jeune agrégé de
philo vous l'avez raconté dans la nuit
du feu et puis il y a eu l'église du
Saint-Sépulcre dans la vieille ville de
Jérusalem expérience presque charnelle
avec le Christ tel que vous décrivez les
choses vous en êtes revenu avec ce livre
le défi de Jérusalem première expérience
très seule en plein désert l'autre
expérience dans une foule étouffante
l'une vous a fait croire en Dieu alors
que vous étiez athée et l'autre a
renforcé votre foi c'est en sac c'est
deux étapes ont été marquantes dans
votre vie oui totalement mais je crois
que beaucoup d'entre nous reçoivent des
des éblouissements des révélations mais
les mettre dans leur poche parce que
c'est gênant parce qu'il faudrait tout
repenser à partir de là parce qu'une
révélation c'est une révolution donc je
crois que beaucoup de gens vivent des
phénomènes entre guillemets étranges
mais décide de s'en débarrasser d'autant
plus dans notre époque qui est
totalement matérialiste et qui a des
explications matérialistes chimiques
biologiques
psychanalytique pour tout
donc oui moi j'ai vécu deux grands
moments en 1989 je suis rentré dans le
désert du Sahara athée et j'en suis
ressorti croyant parce que je me suis
perdu mais dans tous les sens du terme
perdu physiquement mais aussi j'ai perdu
l'être que j'étais peut-être que j'ai eu
peur et que certaines choses peuvent
arriver quand on ne domine plus quand on
est plus dans l'idéal de la contrôle et
moi j'étais totalement dans cette idéale
du contrôle donc ça c'était la
découverte de nuit mystique la
découverte de Dieu du Dieu pour moi de
toutes les religions en tout cas des
trois monothéistes et puis effectivement
ça a développé chez moi un intérêt pour
pour les religions toutes je me suis mis
à énormément lire les les textes des
grandes religions du monde les grands
poètes mystiques vous poétesse mystiques
et puis un jour j'ai lu les quatre
évangiles que j'avais jamais lu à la
suite une nuit c'est court
et j'ai été bouleversé par cette
histoire bouleversée par la mise en
avant de l'amour
l'amour qui doit remplacer toutes les
autres relations humaines qui sont
généralement le calcul l'intérêt ou la
peur tout d'un coup à la place de tout
ça mettez l'amour impossible fou et
c'est pour ça que ça m'a séduit et donc
j'ai développé une réflexion sur le
christianisme avec aussi une enquête
historique philosophique critique et
puis voilà je me considérais comme
chrétien et et quand je suis parti à
Jérusalem ce christianisme
d'intellectuel est devenu charnel parce
que j'ai vécu au Saint-Sépulcre vraiment
une expérience de présence qui qui est
perçu par mes sens qui a comme complété
ce christianisme intellectuel évidemment
ces troublant quand vous racontez cela
et moi je j'ai eu cette réflexion vous
qui avez écrit sur Freud fondateur de la
psychanalyse à aucun moment vous vous
dites que votre cerveau a pu créer ses
sensations ne serait-ce que pour ne pas
être décevant vis-à-vis du pape et du
Vatican qui vous avait demandé de faire
ce voyage ah bah vous connaissez les les
rouages de la psychanalyse
des explications matérialistes je suis
agrégée de philo donc j'étais même payé
pour fournir ce genre de
d'explication non l'expérience résiste à
ce type d'interprétation qu'il
aplatissent d'abord tout simplement je
ne vais pas imaginer qu'une telle chose
puisse arriver donc je ne l'attendais
même pas ensuite je dis pas du tout dans
un degré d'insatisfaction tel qu'il
fallait absolument que quelque chose
m'arrive ensuite au Vatican j’avais dit
j'accepte le voyage mais je n'accepte
pas le livre je ferai un livre que s'il
se passe quelque chose
donc
non non c'est l'éruption de quelque
chose dans le réel
d'inattendu d'exceptionnel d'unique qui
qui a fait ça et ma foi
n'est qu'un consentement à la réalité
et d'en tenir compte
la religion la foi les croyances sont
des sujets qui sont devenus très
sensibles dans notre époque très
polémique des sujets qui font peur aux
sociétés modernes qui sont presque
tabous et vous avez dit un jour les gens
ignorent de plus en plus la Bible qu'on
la dédaigne religieusement ou
spirituellement c'est la liberté de
chacun mais on ne peut pas la dédaigner
culturellement on est fait de ça
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là
moi je crois que le salut passe par la
connaissance il faut connaître
l'histoire des religions il faut
connaître les religions des autres moi
j'ai écrit sur des religions qui ne sont
pas les miennes des textes qu'on fait le
tour du monde comme Monsieur Ibrahim et
les fleurs du Coran etc mais avec un
immense respect en fait ce qui manque
c'est peut-être le respect pour
considérer ces objets ces objets sont
devenus
des lieux de dissension d'opposition de
guerre ou de rejets je crois que non il
faut il faut il faut il faut développer
son attention à à tout dans le monde aux
êtres mais aussi à ce qui fait vibrer le
cœur des êtres aux valeurs qui qui
commande leur gestes nous vous
conseillez à tous les croyants et non
croyons d'aller lire l'Ancien Testament
le Nouveau Testament et le Coran bien
sûr d'abord parce que c'est passionnant
et puis
et puis c'est un texte qui continuait à
s'écrire la Bible parce que
c'est suffisamment imparfait
voire parfois obscur et très souvent
contradictoire pour que votre esprit
s'exerce c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la
vraie éducation religieuse est une éduc
une éducation critique exactement comme
on lit un texte de philosophie vous êtes
obligé d'interpréter et de questionner
et de questionner quand vous lisez les
quatre évangiles votre lecture en
constituant un cinquième vous n'y
échappez pas autrement c'est que vous
êtes passif et vous êtes abruti donc
véritablement moi ce qu'il faut enlever
c'est c'est cette séparation de l'esprit
philosophique et l'esprit religieux moi
qui suis un homme passionné par le 18e
siècle et qui a écrit ma thèse sur
Diderot je crois au contact qu'il faut
prendre l'esprit philosophique pour
considérer le fait religieux mais pas
pour le supprimer
c'est surprenant tout ce que vous dites
parce que vous venez d'une famille athée
et cet enfance vous la passez à
Sainte-Foy-lès-Lyon je prononce bien
dans la métropole lyonnaise vous
observez la ville et la vie depuis le
balcon de vos parents vous dites le
monde m'était donné comme un spectacle
et vous avez d'ailleurs pris l'habitude
d'écrire en hauteur j'écris toujours au
dernier étage de ma maison dites-vous
pourquoi ça vous aide à prendre de la
distance à surplomber un peu le monde
je suis un oiseau écrivain il faut que
je sois à la campagne j'écris dans le
donjon à Bruxelles j'écris au dernier
étage
oui j'ai besoin d'être entouré de
silence et d'être dans une page blanche
et la distance et la distance
philosophique bien sûr que finalement le
balcon de mon enfance m'offrait puisque
j'avais Lyon et les Monts du Lyonnais
devant moi et puis c'est la distance du
spectacle aussi parce que je suis un
jouisseur et que le monde me passionne
donc j'ai gardé de cet enfance cette
idée de oui d'être en hauteur et de voir
les choses de haut à la lueur de celui
que vous êtes aujourd'hui quel conseil
donneriez-vous au petit garçon que vous
étiez
qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez avant
qu'il ne se lance dans la vie
qu'il avait raison
mais je crois qu'une vie réussie c'est
des rêves d'enfants accomplis et donc
l'enfant que j'étais rêvait de voyager
de parcourir le monde rêver d'écrire des
histoires qui pourraient passionner les
gens et je l'ai fait j'ai dit le petit
garçon avait raison j'ai prêté mes
moyens d'adultes mon instruction
d'adulte au petit garçon que j'étais
parmi les figures très importantes de
votre enfant s'il y a votre grand-père
le roi de mes premières années
dites-vous artisan joyeux sertisseur il
m'a transmis son regard attentif sur le
monde l'attachement au travail et vous
avez une anecdote absolument magnifique
sur lui il récoltait tous les soirs très
soigneusement la poussière d'or qui
était restée sur son tablier lorsqu'il
est mort à l'âge de 66 ans il avait
réussi à couler si lingots d'or grâce à
cette poussière ce qui a permis à son
épouse votre grand-mère de vivre plus
confortablement que si elle n'avait dû
vivre qu'avec sa retraite d'artisans
l'histoire est sublime qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit de lui qu'est-ce qu'elle dit de vous
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a apporté c'est
mon modèle c'est un homme assis
lui il était assis à son atelier qui
essaye de faire le mieux possible lui
des bijoux moi des textes et avec la
vertu de la patience moi la patience
n'était pas dans mes données de
caractère au départ il a c'est quelque
chose que j'ai appris et
puis la passion de la patience puisque
finalement il y a que la passion qui
donne la patience et puis et puis cette
idée qu'effectivement cette poussière
d'or c'était rien du tout moi chaque
soir je me moque élu je disais mes
grands-pères il y a rien il me dit tu
verras et effectivement ça a sauvé ma
grand-mère à sa mort elle a pu vivre de
ça et c'est donc aussi moi j'ai comme
l'idée que je fais de la poussière d'or
aussi pour les gens que j'aime
vous trouvez insupportable au regard
qu'on porte aujourd'hui sur la
vieillesse sur les personnes âgées vous
qui avez eu un tel amour et un tel
respect pour vos anciens vous trouvez
que notre société malmaine les anciens
clairement oui il vaut mieux être un
vieillard au Moyen-Orient que en Europe
parce que les vieilles personnes restent
intégrées dans la famille ce qu'on a
fait nous pendant des siècles et qu'on
ne fait plus
aujourd'hui on construit des endroits
pour se débarrasser des vieilles
personnes
on marche sur la tête je ne comprends
pas cette
marchand derrière il y a une société
marchande ils sont plus utiles à la
société ils ne produisent plus allez hop
on attend juste de s'en débarrasser
alors c'est c'est
chacun a des vertus qui sont utiles pour
les autres âges je veux dire quand on a
eu la chance enfant d'avoir un
grand-père qui qui me faisait aimer les
animaux qui me faisaient découvrir les
plantes qui allaient pécher au bord du
Rhône moi je m'ennuyais comme un rat
mort mais en fait non parce que je
rêvais et je consacrais des heures à la
rêverie c'est essentiel dans ma vie la
rêverie c'est mon pétrole la rêverie
vous voyez bon bah chacun je peux
apporter quelque chose aux autres et
vous allez même plus loin vous dites
vieillir ce n'est pas ce raccornir c'est
grandir c'est-à-dire qu'en plus moi j'ai
vu dans dans ma propre vie des choses
s'améliorer en vieillissant d'abord je
suis plutôt les rang vieillissant qui a
20 ans oui j'étais j'avais des
certitudes qui me rendaient intolérants
et puis aussi je travaille beaucoup plus
facilement et mieux
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui je suis
beaucoup plus productif
je ne perds pas mon temps je me connais
j'évite les pièges etc donc
oui oui on gagne des choses on
s'essouffle un peu plus mais
intellectuellement c'est beaucoup mieux
j'ai un document à vous proposer Eric
Emmanuel Schmitt il s'agit d'un document
proposé par les Archives nationales qui
sont nos partenaires dans cette émission
il s'agit d'une fiche des services de
renseignement français sur un certain
Adolf Hitler rédigé en 1924 quand Hitler
est en prison pour trouble à l'ordre
public il y est écrit Adolf Jacob Hitler
première erreur Jacob n'était pas son
deuxième prénom et cela pouvait laisser
croire qu'il avait des origines juives
rumeurs de l'époque un démenti par les
historiens depuis plusieurs autres
erreurs apparaissent sur sa date et son
lieu de naissance et puis aux données
objectives s'ajoutent des commentaires
intéressants le Mussolini allemand de il
écrit n'est pas un imbécile mais un très
à droite démagogue il est question de sa
tentative de coup d'État le 8 novembre
1923 contre le gouvernement bavarois qui
aurai-je cite échouer lamentablement
selon l'agent qui rédige cette fiche et
enfin toujours selon cette agent Hitler
ne serait que l'instrument de puissance
supérieure à l'époque beaucoup pensaient
que Hitler était la marionnette du
général ludendorf l'histoire a montré
que il avait été très loin d'être un
pantin je m'adresse à celui qui s'est
lancé dans la réécriture romancée de la
vie d'Hitler dans la part de l'autre
c'est c'est ce livre que vous inspire ce
document truffé d'erreur
que ça m'inspire c'est que que ça soit
un officier comme ça de renseignements
ou même des romanciers ou des historiens
toujours Hitler c'est l'autre toujours
Hitler c'est celui qui n'est pas comme
nous alors moi j'ai écrit la part de
l'autre pour montrer que Hitler c'est
nous si
Hitler c'est moi si je préfère un bouc
émissaire à l'analyse de la complexité
des causes c'est moi si je crois que
j'ai toujours raison etc etc donc quand
j'ai écrit la part de l'autre j'ai créé
un double roman effectivement d'un côté
la vie du vrai Hitler qui rate
l'Académie des Beaux-Arts en 1909 à
Vienne et chapitre suivant l'Académie
l'histoire de Adolphe h reçu aura des
fesses à l'Académie du Mozart quand même
voilà mais qui va lui se développer sur
l'épanouissement et non pas sur la
frustration le manque et une théorie
pour interpréter son échec et du coup je
raconte deux vingtième siècle le 20e
siècle avec Adolf Hitler malheureusement
et peut-être le 20e siècle sans Adolf
Hitler en faisant de la géopolitique
fiction donc c'est à la fois un roman
historique et une uchronie moi ça m'a
passionné d'écrire ce livre mais ça m'a
aussi alerté et inquiété je me suis dit
que c'était très facile de devenir nazi
et sur et aussi très facile de devenir
Hitler il suffit de d'être en refus de
la complexité du monde et à la recherche
de solutions simples et dès que je vois
quelqu'un brandir des solutions simples
je m'inquiète vous pensez à qui à quoi
il y a beaucoup de de
politique qui ne nous apporte des
solutions simples et nous disent c'est
très simple et qui sont dans du dans une
idéologie du bouc émissaire à partir du
moment où on est là à mon avis on pense
plus et on est dangereux ça veut dire
aussi que les drames de l'histoire
peuvent se jouer à rien un petit
accident comme celui de ce refus dont
vous parlez et puis vous avez la grande
question des historiens c'est est-ce que
l'histoire qui fait est-ce l'histoire
qui fait les hommes ou les hommes qui
font l'histoire je trouve que Hitler est
un cas qui nous montre que parfois ce
sont les individus qui font l'histoire
au sens où il y a une dimension il y
aurait eu de toute façon dans
l'Allemagne des années 30 un
gouvernement de droite du droit
d'autoritaire et solide et dur à cause
de cette stupidité qui était le traité
de Versailles mais la composante
antisémite c'est la marque hitlérienne
et voyez cette obsession individuelle de
cet homme cette maladie qu'il a
transmise à l'Allemagne
elle a quand même conduit une guerre
avec 52 millions de morts
à vous présenter Eric Emmanuel Schmitt
ça fait partie des rituels de cette
émission
la première photo la voici
c'est une photo de classe en Suède avec
des élèves travaillant sur des écrans
après 15 ans de numérique et de
tablettes le pays revient au bon vieux
manuel scolaire une étude a montré que
le niveau des jeunes suédois avait
baissé notamment en lecture et en
compréhension écrite vous qui préférez
le stylo au clavier je vous ai entendu
le dire vous qui écrivez des livres ça
vous réjouit que l'on tire des
enseignements et que l'on revienne au
papier et au bon vieux bouquin moi j'ai
pas de théorie à l'avance là-dessus si
c'est bien si l'expérience montre que il
faut en partie éviter les camps moi
j'avoue que je suis client des deux
j'écris à la main mais j'ai créé aussi
sur l'écran et je suis pas du tout
mauvais dans le maniement de ces
instruments là
mais j'ai remarqué une chose c'est que
quand par exemple je lis un livre sur
écran ou quand je le lis à la main je ne
retiens pas de la même façon un livre
que je dis sur du papier je le retiens
pour toute ma vie ce sur écran une
semaine après je l'ai oublié donc il se
passe quelque chose alors un neurologue
pourrait m'expliquer qui fait que mon
acuité
némique n'est pas la même mais seuls les
études objectives nous apprendre quelque
chose là-dessus moi je suis pas fétiche
quel est votre rapport au numérique au
réseau sociaux alors aux réseaux sociaux
0 j'ai quelqu'un maintenant j'ai
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe pour moi parce
que je veux pas savoir mais en même
temps je sais que c'est utile qu'est-ce
que vous ne voulez pas savoir les
commentaires des obligeants les
critiques les choses désagréables
c'est-à-dire les réseaux sociaux c'était
fait pour
pour communiquer et pour faire tomber
les murs et ça en adressé je ne sais
combien les gens sont dans des
communautés où ils pensent tous la même
chose et ils vont jamais à côté dans une
autre communauté donc en fait on a
construit des murs et des murs et des
murs moi je préfère les ponts au mur
c'est intéressant c'est ce que je disais
en début d'émission une deuxième photo
vous allez probablement le reconnaître
il s'agit de Matteo zuppy cardinal
italien qui a pour mission de négocier
la paix en Ukraine envoyé par le pape à
Moscou et à Kiev selon vous la paix peut
arriver par des hommes d'église et des
hommes de foi
alors moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va peut-être vous surprendre
effectivement je pense que
la religion n'est pas à jeter comme un
facteur de désordre dans le monde les
religions mais comme plutôt des moyens
d'accéder à la paix d'abord au cœur de
chaque religion il y a la même chose le
désir de lutter contre l'égoïsme de
développer la générosité individuelle de
se raccorder avec les autres dans toutes
les religions il y a ça ensuite si les
religions sont conscientes qu'au fond
elles ont le même cœur
je pense que elles peuvent créer des
points d'entente et pour moi Jérusalem
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit le défi de
Jérusalem et vraiment le lieu qui sur
terre dit ça c'est d'abord un lieu où
Dieu a dit écoutez-moi puisqu'il a créé
le premier monothéisme le judaïsme le
deuxième l'accomplissement du
christianisme du Jésus se fait là et le
troisième puisque
il y a le rocher d'Abraham Mahomet est
venu en songe et puis est parti au ciel
depuis là dans la tradition musulmane
donc mais le problème c'est que après
avoir parlé là en disant écoutez-moi je
pense que maintenant il tient à notre
discours il dit entendez-vous et je
crois que l'entente elle peut venir des
religions dans la mesure où les
religions doivent se rendre compte
qu'elles sont elles ont le même père les
religions où les hommes les hommes les
religions ont la même origine je veux
dire ces trois manières de dire la même
chose
et je pense que les religions devraient
à peine sont en elle-même si elles ont
la mémoire de ce qu'elles sont un appel
à la fraternité plutôt cofratricide le
frein tricide c'est l'oubli de l'origine
les frères sont fratricides quand ils
oublient le père ou la mère quand ils
oublient qu'ils sont ici d'une origine
commune on passe du fratricide à la
fraternité quand on se rend compte que
on n'est pas à l'origine de sa propre
histoire mais qu'on est la suite d'une
autre histoire et qu'on doit inclure
l'autre dans la cohésion totale de cette
histoire donc je crois qu'en fait par le
religieux si le religieux développe la
conscience de son historicité et de sa
proximité avec d'autres religions oui on
peut trouver des portes j'ai une
dernière question
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt qui est en lien
avec le lieu dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui nous sommes entourés de
quatre statues qui représentent chacune
une vertu la sagesse la prudence la
justice et l'éloquence laquelle de ces
vertus vous caractérise le plus vous
plaît le PLUS celles dont vous avez
envie de parler
je suis philosophe de formation
philosophie ça veut dire amour la
sagesse et je pense que que dans la
sagesse il y a toutes les autres vertus
qui sont représentées par les autres
statues pour moi c'est essentiel
ce n'est pas forcément la recherche du
vrai
parce que le vrai est parfois
inaccessible c'est la recherche d'un
monde vivable pour nous tous avec une
certaine harmonie et ce sera le mot de
la fin merci merci infiniment d'avoir
été avec nous dans un monde un regard de
nous avoir apporté votre monde et votre
regard merci beaucoup et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine à
très très vite sur public c'est ma merci
[Musique]